Chuck career creator close close close
close close to cloves back up a little
bit
good good are the Liberals going quick
test when they go low
perfect roll up it's time for just
between us just between us
gun rights are stronger than ever in
fact that same panel that's advocating
stronger background checks is also about
to pass a breakthrough pro-gun measure
this week look at this in a major
victory for gun rights advocates a House
Committee advanced the Republican
concealed carry or a Sur prosity Act
backed by the NRA would allow gun owners
to carry their concealed weapons across
state lines with a permit our rights
should not end where a state line ends
this is about the equal access of you're
pro-choice right of self-defense yes
suck it snowflakes pro-choice is our
thing now next we're coming for their
electric cars we're gonna make them run
on elephant blood let's break this down
what is gun reciprocity first off don't
worry I know reciprocity sounds like
some why a novel about high schoolers
with awesome powers and that's because
it is I wrote it
but the reciprocity I'm talking about is
way cooler gun reciprocity means that if
you're allowed to carry a gun in your
state you're allowed to do it in any
other state and twelve states don't have
any restrictions beyond the minimum
federal requirements live in those
states it's awesome any day could turn
into a die hard movie Wyoming is like
85% Bruce Willis sees this new bill is
beautiful because it lowers the bar
across the country so that every state
has to abide by the loosest concealed
carry laws americans love lowering the
bar it's so much easier to get over it
that way no to get specific let's look
at the laws in a state like Georgia say
you're a convicted domestic abuser who
lives there you have a conceal and carry
permit because Georgia allows you to
despite your abuse conviction then you
come to a liberal hellhole like New York
that doesn't allow domestic abusers to
carry guns I know crazy under the
reciprocity bill you'd still be allowed
to carry that gun alright I know you're
thinking Jordan a domestic abuser is not
a good guy with a gun yes well of course
in Georgia he's not but in New York
maybe you would bank
it's like Sinatra said if you can make
it here with a gun you can make it
anywhere with a gun reciprocity is like
if all the gunslingers in HBO's West
world started showing up and other shows
with their guns America just put more
bang in the big bang theory and just
between us it gets even better because
America is still gunning as and it's not
just the adults Wisconsin's new law that
allows hunters of any age to carry a
weapon has already led to licenses being
sold to infants ten mentored hunting
licenses were sold over the last two
weeks all to children under the age of
one
the terrible twos just got real it's it
is great that this past in Wisconsin but
you know what's even greater Wisconsin
became the 35th state with no minimum
hunting age they may not be able to
stand their ground yet but they can
definitely do tummy time on their ground
gun advocates are gun racking up wins
all over no matter what the libs are
celebrating I mean just look at our
president you really think this guy will
allow meaningful gun control I have a
license to carry in New York can you
believe that nobody knows you all whew
cool
you can tell Trump's a pro rule number
one whenever you shoot look dope as hell
now remember this whole thing is just
between us don't let any of those
pomegranate juicy and liberals hear
about reciprocity and especially don't
let them call this one number which will
connect them to the representatives so
they can weigh in on the national carry
reciprocity oh yes it's happening this
week oh yeah I definitely do not take a
picture of this and definitely do not
post it on social media they get their
heads on this these liberals are going
to grab onto these dangerous opinions
conceal and carry them and then whip
them out when we least expect it
[Music]